let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
and i'm just getting word here i'm just
getting word here i think i think that
person who trump endorsed
uh is joining us now um his name is jd
mandel jd
mandel is that is that you
yes hi jd mandel thank you for having me
jd how how are you how are you uh you
know um
uh i i you know i've had better days you
know what what does your hat what does
your hat say
it says uh donald trump knows my name
okay okay so i mean he he called me you
know
i'm gonna i'm gonna say this um really
didn't expect it but this past weekend
he called me out by name at the ohio
rally yeah i mean i think i think it
really pushed me in the polls a little
bit um
so
you know i appreciate the uh the shout
out well uh maybe we'll pull up that
video here of of trump um actually
um endorsing you what uh what appears to
be endorsing you on stage
i mean love to hear my name you know
yeah jd mandel
let's well he he kind of got your name
wrong there at first jd yeah you know
he's an older guy you know he said you
know he mixed up the d and the p but he
got there but he got right there right
so let's let's listen let's listen to
your mussolini jesus as it appears
you're a trump supporter right you love
trump he supports me so i support him oh
okay so that's how it is you know yeah
it's kind of a circle jerk kind of thing
i get it i get it sounds like trumpism
um so here here is here is your
mussolini jesus
appearing to say your name that's what
they're waiting for they're waiting for
one race you know we've endorsed dr oz
we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel here i am and he's
doing great they're all doing good he
said you were doing great there uh jd
mandel
oh man you know again i wasn't really
expecting it but as soon as does that
give you a boner it really seems like it
gave you a boner there
i mean you if you hear your name said by
trump on stage in front of you know a
few dozen people it is quite a trip oh
okay well it might be for someone who
thinks he's uh the republican jesus but
for someone who doesn't
anyway so let's get back to the other
people in this race were you how many
votes did you receive yesterday um in
the ohio prime minister
like counting my own
did you write yourself in is that what
you're saying uh i did i mean my name
wasn't officially on the ballot but
oh i took advantage of an opportunity
and i i you know i was a write-in you
went ahead and voted for yourself yep
yep okay well that that makes sense
because you know you had a couple other
opponents on the ballot you actually had
jd vance which is i think who trump
originally endorsed are you aware of
that and he kind of shares the same
first yeah but you know what
i guess he just knew that a uh a prado
ohioan like myself uh yeah should be the
candidate okay well there's also another
guy on the ballot that appears to have a
similar name as yours his name is josh
mandel so jay is his first initial i
don't know if p is his middle initial or
not i have no idea but his last name is
mandel so he shares the same last name a
lot of people i will say this a lot of
people are saying that josh mandel
photoshopped himself into uh photos uh
while serving you know if you look at
his hands they're a little bit darker
than his skin some people said he
photoshopped himself so so you don't
like josh mandel you're not you're not
no no no no is is is he your cousin or
something you know you guys share the
last name i didn't know if like it was
your cousin no i mean look i'm not going
to do the 23andme and try to figure out
our relationship but from what i
understand we are not related
um sure hope not um
but uh no i am my own man and uh i at
least for the most of what i know we are
not related we just happen to be you
know a couple mandels in one town you
know
ah just a couple mandels in the same
town well that's that's very interesting
uh so how do you think because it
appears that jd vance is going to win
the primary he's going to be the
republican candidate on the
ballot for the midterm election even
though he
you probably did you see the the lincoln
project ad i just played where he's a
never trumper that he's been a never
trumper for a long time yeah
uh
jd vance is a backstabbing hypocrite oh
he is okay well
so so you're saying i know he stole my
girlfriend in high school oh he did he
did this is news this is news everyone
breaking news
uh jd vance stole jd mandel's
girlfriend in high school and it seems
like you're very upset about this i am i
mean i i really thought we were going to
go the distance you know we were going
to get married we're going to have kids
we're going to get that you and you and
jd are you in this this
lovely lady oh my well my girlfriend and
i wanted her to be my wife i thought it
was really going to be that you know
we're a couple high school sweethearts
and uh you know jd
uh pretended to be this jd oh um you
know
so this isn't the first time he's trying
to impersonate you i guess i mean look
we were at a party okay we were playing
seven minutes in heaven okay i was
supposed to go in there with my
girlfriend okay
and then next thing i know i'm going to
get us a couple drinks i'm like where's
lindsay and they said they're in the
closet together with jd and i said what
do you mean and you're like yeah you say
i'm jd i'm jade i said i'm jd and i was
like i'm jd i was getting us drinks and
they said oh no she's in the closet
right now with jd they're playing seven
minutes in heaven
and i said whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
this sounds like seven minutes in hell
to me
so so then they come out of the closet
bingo bango next thing i know
they're dating oh okay so he stole your
girlfriend and you could you could hear
her in the closet she was like oh jd oh
jd between kisses she was like oh jd and
i was like i'm jd i'm jd
right and then and then she comes out
again i tell you she comes out and she's
like i'm with this jd oh so you know
what shows
what was that what was it again i said
[ __ ] jd vance oh okay okay not not
not [ __ ] you jd no why but she
and me running right right in you know
oh you know i really thought that i was
gonna be uh right become that kid you
know i was gonna be i could have been a
contender you know like i thought i was
gonna be
i had a real shot okay because he said
your name on stage i get it so so let's
talk about jd vance as the candidate not
as the guy who stole your your
girlfriend right um and you [ __ ] your
girlfriend let's talk about the guy who
won
appears to win the primary of the
republican last night um jd vance he's
got a lot of views um that seemed to be
kind of i don't know anti-american
almost to me
and even even to his opponent tim ryan
um who is the person who won the
democratic ticket tim ryan um is the
person who's going to run as the
democrat so we have in the in the
midterm election you're going to have jd
vance the guy who who stole and [ __ ]
your girlfriend and then tim ryan
probably the guy who
appears more like a guy he would steal
right and in fact your girlfriend um but
those two are going to compete in this
race what do you have to say about jd
vance you know him appearing to not be
as america first as maybe the the
fascist uh maga trump humping movement
like you're a part of
right
what tell us about that what
what i'm sorry what did you just call me
i i said you're part of the fascist maga
trump-humping movement oh yeah yeah the
q and the q anon movement
yeah yeah i i wasn't misspeaking jfk
junior is coming back yeah right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's let's let's not get let's not get
off
let's get on let's get okay
about jd vance okay he called america a
joke okay he said uh our country's kind
of a joke i'm sorry uh our founding
fathers didn't think that it's like i
mean get with it you know it's like if
you truly are a patriot america is not a
joke right america is the city upon a
hill right that shining beacon of light
right that place in which other people
come to us as they're saving grace okay
okay so so you're saying you're saying
that
if you had a candidate that thought that
jd vance was the joke instead of
jd vance thinking the country was a joke
you might vote for them is that what
you're saying
you're saying that way sorry say that
one more time if you had a candidate out
there in your because you live in ohio
you're a voter in ohio yeah i hope i
hope you're registered to vote if you
went and wrote in yourself i'm in ohio
yes okay and so if you're registered in
ohio wouldn't you want to vote for a
candidate that is against jd vance
saying that our country is a joke and
that he's kind of a joke and he
definitely would probably want to make
sure
uh to not make money like in china or
overseas it sounds a little hunter
biden-ish doesn't it it does you know
where's jd's laptop am i right well i i
want to know i i would like to be
writing a sequel to his dumb book
did you read this book can you read i
mean i guess i should ask you that first
can you read hillbilly wannabe that's
what it is yeah right right well he is a
hillbilly wannabe for sure but but it
sounds like you would vote for a
candidate who was on the same page as
you about jd vance the guy who stole
your girlfriend you should you should
want to vote you should want to vote for
someone from ohio who wants to work for
the american people who doesn't just up
and leave for his hollywood elites right
his leftist friends right go and be a
correspondent on cnn cnn wait wait do
you mean do you mean jd vance the guy
that stole your girlfriend was on on
fake news as a correspondent he was paid
by fake news yeah he was a an
analyst
analyst oh i i see i see
you're not you're not it's analyst it's
analyst it's spelled like anal well
right right
anal
ist
analysis he's an analyst okay okay fair
enough
okay tony i'm not over here writing
dictionaries okay i'm really reading
them you know well that analyst he's an
analyst with the fake news network cnn
apparently yeah so you would vote for
you would vote for a guy who was opposed
to this stuff then is what you're saying
oh i would most definitely vote for a
guy that was totally against jd vance
that's [ __ ]
girlfriend stealing wannabe hillbilly i
i well
i don't blame you i don't blame you that
you would vote against
jd vance and make sure to keep ohio in
ohio right to make sure it's someone who
is ohio who is born in ohio raised in
ohio four ohioans who doesn't call
america a joke who doesn't call our
country a joke exactly that's who that's
who the people should be voting for
you know i found a video
of of a candidate and i believe this is
uh his name is tim ryan he's running on
the ticket too i i can't figure out from
this video if he's a democrat or
republican maybe you can tell me uh if
you'd vote for this candidate here um
let's play it here see if you'd vote for
this candidate people may not always
agree with my rhetoric but i think
unfortunately our country is kind of a
joke
that's what i said sandy vance left ohio
for san francisco to make millions in
investing companies that profit from
globalization and free trade he became a
celebrity cnn analyst and a big hit at
washington cocktail parties now vance
says he feels out of place in ohio and
he wants to represent you in the senate
what a joke
i'm tim ryan and i approve this message
[Music]
so you think people may not know
jd jd do you think you would vote for
tim ryan over jd vance yeah i would vote
for if i knew that tim ryan was running
and i didn't have to write myself in i
would have voted for tim ryan oh would
you look this is great this is great
news because i believe the news is i
don't think it's official yet but i
believe the news is that tim ryan if you
are registered in ohio you will be able
to go vote for him in november during
the midterm election jd well i'm gonna
vote for i mean you know clearly i only
got eight votes you know including mine
but wait wait you had eight people vote
for you
yeah
eight eight people including myself i
mean one one also my my mom and then my
sister so you know but eight people
voted that's pretty good that's pretty
good eight votes on the ballot that's
pretty if you're telling me that this
guy tim ryan i don't know who this guy
is but if you're telling me this guy is
running in november oh [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
he's running he's running he's a he's a
democrat he's a democrat running in ohio
he's on the democratic ticket so so go
vote go vote for yeah he's a he's a
democrat he's a democrat that's right
that's right and he's he's he's making
sure to be against uh jd vance being a a
traitor to ohio going to san francisco
making money off china and all the
elitist and then being an analyst as you
call it analysts on fake news
yeah tony i feel like you're putting me
between a rock and a hard place right
now oh yeah you're telling me that this
guy's anti-jd which i'm anti-jd okay
right right you're you know all the
points that i brought up during the
during this interview you know tim ryan
said exactly those same things it's
almost like we're on the same wavelength
i know and you're telling me that this
guy is going up against jd vance in
november yeah well q anon is a hypocrite
listen listen jd q anon is a hell of a
drug it's a hell of a drug and you
really
you really should maybe check out um you
know you know some things on the side of
facts and that might help you through
this process jd it really might help you
through this process i don't know i'm
feeling i'm feeling very confused right
now
um
i don't know i don't know what to
believe anymore well i tell you what
we're gonna take a break and i
appreciate you joining us jd please come
back uh more during this election to
give us your insight into how you're
feeling about uh tim ryan running
against your enemy jd vance yeah um and
i got a special a special commercial for
you so don't forget to watch through the
break jd
um because there is a there is a special
trump fund out there for people who are
sad and broken like you speaking of the
the truth um here i want to go to did
you did you see that howard the what
howard stern had said about this yeah in
court decision yes i don't think he's i
think he's i think that's totally fine i
think he's spot on here um a lot of
people don't like howard stern for a lot
of different reasons um i i was always a
fan of howard because he is provocative
um and he's provocative in a way that
makes you think again kind of like a
comedian would make you think about an
issue but he really does get a uh
he gets straight to the point here and
the reason why we have the situation
that we have and if you're wondering out
there why the situation is what it is
just listen to howard here and he'll
kind of explain it this really isn't
rocket science i mean he puts it in so
many words because howard stern is good
with words right but this isn't rocket
science of why we're in the situation he
just has a fabulous way of describing it
let's listen abortion come out how women
vote for this agenda is beyond me how
you would how who the hell wants to
carry a baby that you do not want
and again the people who uh carry these
uh babies who don't want them don't
raise these kids and then we're stuck
with them society is stuck with them the
people who are anti-abortion they don't
give to charity they don't raise these
kids i don't know who they think's gonna
raise them
but um you know
you saw men if men got pregnant it would
be a different story no man would want
to be raped and then have to carry his
rapists uh baby
uh i think i think that's probably one
of one of the best points that he makes
in this uh this little two-minute clip
here is that look if this was reversed
and men had the burden of the state
telling them what medical procedure they
can and cannot get and forcing them to
carry
uh a baby to term this this would be
completely different so totally we we
would not even be having this discussion
because this opinion would not even
exist the only reason why it exists is
because men want to [ __ ] tell women
what the [ __ ] they want to do because
that's the truth of the matter that we
have here is it is men in this country
weird ass [ __ ] freak ass men wanting
weirdos [ __ ] weirdos that they are so
concerned with a woman's vagina why are
you so concerned with a woman's body you
[ __ ] weirdo they are very concerned
with something that they probably won't
get that's right let's just be honest
about it right i mean i mean man they're
they're completely obsessed with
people's genitalia in bathrooms it's the
same [ __ ] it's the same
minority who want to ban macbooks
because it's crt it's the same minority
that want to tell lgbtq people what the
[ __ ] they can and can't do
and who they can love and who they can
marry and what they can identify as this
is really [ __ ] these are [ __ ]
weirdos they're fascist but they're
weirdos and howard stern has it right on
the head that there's no [ __ ] way
that men in this country would let some
[ __ ] weirdo ass men tell them what
they could and couldn't do about their
own pregnancy let me tell you that is
one [ __ ] thing that men would
not put up with this in this country and
women shouldn't either and us men should
not put up with [ __ ] men telling
women what to do either that's for
goddamn sure because they'll come for
you next and they're coming for women's
contraception that's the next step well
let's listen to what howard says how he
wraps it up in a bow here
um men were ready to tear this country
down because we asked them to wear a
mask let alone have some baby they don't
want yeah but okay how did we get to
this point
the electoral college says and i guess
this was set up back in the good old
days
because they wanted everyone to have
some kind of representation but here's
what happened three million voters
were the majority who voted for hillary
clinton but they ended up with trump we
got a
minority president
who held views that were the minority of
this country
so much so that he lost by three million
votes and he became president and then
he did the country of favor and found
the most radical supreme court justices
who all agreed
that abortion was now he alludes to it
here but he didn't find the most radical
uh the most radical supreme court
justices were bought and paid for and
placed on a list and donald trump was
forced that was the deal he made with
the devil was that he would pick the
supreme court justice from the
federalist society that's why all the
evangelical christians backed this [ __ ]
grabbing three-time married [ __ ]
non-christian they they elected him
because he agreed to make sure that this
what we're going through right now would
happened i mean if anyone wants to get
mad at anyone people should be looking
to people like george conway all right i
think he's your friend you know he's
like oh who he's a never trumper no man
george conway is nobody's friend he will
at any moment turn his back on you and
then also simultaneously stab it but uh
he is you know huge i think he had a
tweet yesterday that was pushing
why this decision was was so correct
right it's ahead and saying that roe
versus wade had regressed the
advancement of of women's rights you
know which is insane because it's the
complete opposite and so george conway
you know one of the people the federal
society the one of the people like tony
said who are the are the you know not
going to say the puppeteers but they are
the people that are [ __ ] pushing and
and pain and and making sure that
certain people are in power they're
lining those things up it's like how do
you think we got to where we are right
now it's because those people were the
ones who are funding it those are the
ones who were making the decision right
right and they just got pissed off right
they just got pissed off that it didn't
happen the way that they wanted it to
happen yeah and that christo makes a
good point here heritage foundation too
yeah yeah mayo says you know just like
his wife kellyanne conway right another
demon in a human form
but
you just asked just ask their daughter
just right yeah she was yeah oh my god
but yeah
again you know
these groups are you know privately
funded right wing fascist think tanks
organizations
foundations whatever you want to call
them but they're the ones that are you
know i mean
the rest of dc is also funded in certain
ways but these are the people if you
want to look at who is the who is
responsible for pushing this type of
this uh type of opinion that has been
dissented you know um you got to look at
george conway kellyanne conway the
heritage foundation the federal society
like these are the people that are the
ones that are
pushing the buttons someone on twitch
here says the crypt keeper you shouldn't
know
you shouldn't call kellyanne conway the
crypt how dare you on my show that is an
insult to the [ __ ] keeper that is an
insult that's right the crypt keeper
should be offended by what you just said
let's listen to what uh the rest of
howard stern's argument here of the
scotus draft decision wrong they've been
on some sort of a secret list that not
so secret list so we ended up with this
scenario
and we also ended up with it when uh
again
you know uh obama didn't get to pick a
supreme court justice so okay so now we
have a minority viewpoint in this
country running the country if it was
the majority viewpoint all right you put
up with it but it's the minority
viewpoint now how much more are we going
to take
how much more of this [ __ ]
that some hillbilly in south dakota gets
a more important vote because he lives
in south dakota now that is a really a
really good point and what he's alluding
to there is the way that we elect the
president is that the the people in
south dakota are in the 2016 election
were afforded way more sway with their
vote than everyone else because it is
true that we get one person one vote in
this country but because of how our uh
our republic works and the presidential
election works especially um there is
more weight
for people in areas where
there is less votes
where there's a higher population now of
course like the state of new york and
the state of california receive more
electoral votes for the college but
that still doesn't matter when you're
talking about if you put together the
right states that someone can lose by
three million votes and still become
president yeah now a lot of people want
to abolish uh that part of our election
system and actually i think the easiest
way is to not abolish it i think the
easiest way is to
um there is a project out there that is
trying to get states to pass their law
to where their state
actually gives their votes for the
college to the majority vote in their
state and as long as we get uh enough
states to do that the the popular vote
in the country should be right who the
president actually becomes rather
whether it's republican democrat or
otherwise if we that's how it should be
right it makes total sense right like
you wouldn't just default and say all
right uh yeah we're gonna go with the
electoral college if you don't win the
popular vote then you don't win the
popular vote but it's like wait wouldn't
that be the majority of people those are
the people who that is the majority of
the population of the united states who
said hey
uh we want this person to be in power we
have we have put our voice on the ballot
and our vote has gone to this person and
then what basically what our electoral
college system says is yeah yeah that's
that's nice that you decided that but
we're going to go a different way right
like you're you know you're you're just
throwing throwing these people saying
that like oh everyone has a voice and
everyone has the right to vote and and
you want to make your you want to make
your voice your vote you know
uh established and heard right but this
is one of those moments where you look
at you said yeah we'll [ __ ] those votes
right right well chris chris points out
chris from youtube points out a good
point here uh we need to do ranked
choice voting as well uh some states do
rank choice voting like maine does rank
choice voting and some other things and
if you guys don't know what ranked
choice voting is go go google it rank
choice voting um it's a very unique way
to make sure that you rank your
candidates so in other words if there's
four candidates on the ballot or there's
six candidates on the ballot you know it
gets rid of this whole third party
[ __ ] argument um we really can toss
that [ __ ] to the side if we get to
ranked choice voting in some of these
states but amanda i'm going to push back
a little bit she says abolish the
electoral college i think there's a way
to actually circumvent the electoral
college in our laws without having to i
think abolishing it is a lot tougher
than actually getting states to say we
are going to give our electoral votes to
the majority of the vote in our state if
this because the state can decide that
the state can pass that law to do that
it is constitutional so there's a
constitutional way to make sure
in this country enough states have to
decide to do that and i i believe it's
only like three or four states away is
kind of the the math so wait wait are
you saying that
we should support states rights
well you know i think i think what we
should do is if the state has the right
to choose how they afford their
electoral college votes then we should
do that but when it comes to someone's
liberty when it comes to someone's
liberty because you get the vote now
they the state does not have the right
to keep you from voting right the state
does not keep you have the right despite
the fact that republicans try to do that
right well i mean i mean i talked about
the 19th amendment yes do you know what
the 19th amendment is
the exact wording no no no the 19th
amendment is the amendment that afforded
women the right to vote right yeah yeah
and i believe suffrage 1920 correct
correct and 22 was it 22 no it's 1919
1920 i believe it was ratified in 1920
so it became official right exactly it
was passed in 1919 and then ratified but
about a year later i believe once the
states ratified it but here we are
almost 100 years over 100 years later
and i'm telling you the next thing is
contraception and then they're going to
come after the women's vote and
everyone's like oh they can't they can't
because of the 19th amendment they go oh
they go after
black people's vote all the time people
of color's vote is at jeopardy all the
time
with these [ __ ] gqp fascists just
because you're white doesn't mean you're
safe just because they can't just say
women can't vote doesn't mean they won't
try to take away your ability to that is
such [ __ ] they are coming after your
right to vote and the reason why i know
they're coming after women's right to
vote is because the the the absolute
uproar you're going to see about this
decision yeah on roe v wade you're going
to see an uproar and they're going to
figure out that holy [ __ ] are our
our constituency is at risk right so we
got to make sure to pare down our
constituencies
the men are the men are speaking the men
are voting exactly right please
that's right let us let let us finish go
back to the kitchen simmer down simmer
down now
go make me a sandwich that's what they
want right don't vote don't speak out
don't protest just go back into the
kitchen
take a little drug to make you calm
and i'll see you at dinner right keep
that aspirin between your legs um you
know and when you do have an abortion
[ __ ] you right and let's hear what
howard says here about about the
unwanted babies this is this is a great
dismount here for this clip let's hear
what he has to say about what we should
do
with all all the unwanted babies um that
these fascists want to want to have in
our country
uh let me tell you something here's what
i say all unwanted children should be
allowed to live at the supreme court
building with those justices and they
should raise every one of those babies
that crackpot uh clarence thomas and
that wife and all of them they can raise
these babies that they want that's right
and and i i i don't i i think that maybe
uh a supreme court uh uh nursery is not
a bad idea i mean if they're gonna pass
this law maybe we should put it on them
yeah i mean for the same people that are
like we gotta protect the children
got to keep them safe we got to make
sure that they're not being trafficked
it's like all right well uh i don't see
you adopting
you know oh pro-life pro-life i don't
see you giving them the resources or or
the money or the organization or or the
programs to make sure that a single
parent a mother that you forced to have
a child get the actual support that she
needs because at the end of the day
that's what's happening right they look
at this and they say oh you know what
you have to have the baby you're like
okay cool fine you forced me to have the
baby right despite the fact that i don't
want to you made me have the baby are
you going to give me the proper
resources to help me prepare the home to
give me the the uh you know the the
tools
to raise this child right the funds to
help raise them so i don't find myself
in crushing debt outside of the fact
that i just you know went to school and
now i'm already in crushing debt but now
like okay i gotta raise another life on
top of my own and and make sure i care
for it will you give me the funds will
you will you point me to the right
program and an organization that will
help me with this and they're like oh
you know what actually we just closed
down the most uh most recent planned
parenthood that was closest to you right
yeah you're like okay well you're gonna
you have another place that i can go no
actually the next one's uh two states
over right and you're like well
what do i do
and then like oh well go get [ __ ] go
get bent go get bent yeah right oh yeah
and when you have the baby when you have
the baby that baby can get bent too
we're not going to help right exactly
speaking speaking of the supreme court
and the lying lying [ __ ] fascist
bought and paid for supreme court
justices did you see the video that
might just touch but i usually lying gop
it's it's trending and that is why the
republicans are scared this morning
they're terrified
that this leaked
i'm talking about the supreme court
decision to overturn roe v wade and
strip away the liberty and the rights of
women
all over this country
don't think they won't come after the
19th amendment either
they're ready they're they're gonna
fight
they're gonna fight
yes it's a constitutional amendment and
some say oh tony tony they'll never take
that constitutional amendment away
they'll never take the the right of
women to vote away oh really
they won't huh they won't try to chip
away
at women's liberty are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
that's what you think
that they're not willing to chip away at
a woman's liberty in this country and
her rights
well good luck with that narrative from
here on out
i've been saying yelling and screaming
for months and months and months that
these fascists are coming for you
and it won't stop it won't stop
at women's right to the autonomy of
their body it will not stop there it
won't stop in the red states in the
cheeto dust confederacy it won't stop
there
they will not quit they will not end the
scourge of fascism around this country
to turn our entire country not just the
red states not just where they have
control
their goal
is for a fascist authoritarian
state
to tell you what you can and cannot do
with your body
to tell you what you can and cannot
consent for your body your children and
your family
they're ready folks
they picked a hill to die on that's
where they want to fight are we going to
stand down in the valley
and yell at
at them to say come down here come down
here and fight us where we want to fight
no we march up on the hill and we fight
the battle that they want to fight they
want to take your [ __ ] liberty away
from you
now is the time now
is the time
to fight
so don't just tweet
get on your feet
march
protest yell scream
be divisive that's right
tony don't say be divisive oh really
oh really you're just gonna you're just
gonna
you're just gonna let fascism take over
the country
because you're unwilling
you're unwilling to call fascism fascism
they're they're concerned about the leak
this morning oh my god can you imagine
who leaked this information
so early
that women in this country would
organize and march against us that's
what they're [ __ ] worried about folks
they're worried now more than ever
that the mobilization
a pro-democracy people in this country
has a head start
on the decision of the supreme court to
take away your
liberty
and all you men out there that are
listening to me thinking oh well what
the hell's this got to do with me hell i
can't have an abortion you think they're
not coming for you
they're ready to turn this into an
authoritarian fascist state they've been
ready for a long [ __ ] time
a long [ __ ] time
they've been ready to turn this into
authoritarian fascist state
it is very clear in this country
what we must do
we must participate in democracy five
thousand percent
you know what scares these fascists more
than anything in the world
not guns not threats
democracy
terrifies them
the will of the people
frightens the holy [ __ ]
out of them
so let's use that weapon
let's use democracy let's show them
what we the people can
do
when we exercise our right to our
democracy and our right to our liberty
and if you today are not standing up
just [ __ ] furious
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
that were bought and paid for for our
supreme court are stripping away our
citizens and our women in this country's
liberty you
are a piece of [ __ ]
garbage and you are not for democracy
i don't give a [ __ ] about pro-life and
pro-choice partial burst abortion i
don't give a
[ __ ]
at this point
this is only about one fight and one
fight only
are you going to let them come and take
your rights
because they're coming
they're coming for the 19th amendment
you don't think you think they're just
gonna stand back and take women's
liberty and then let them vote
to secure it to codify it no they will
do anything in their power anything even
try to commit a coup
on our democracy
overturn our vote overthrow our
constitution
they're willing to do anything and
everything and they will take help from
anyone
including other authoritarians like
vladimir putin
and the scourge of disinformation and
misinformation and lies you lying
[ __ ]
and they've been doing it for decades
it ain't just now this lie about partial
burst abortion get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] that's all a [ __ ] lie
the lies that they spread on social
media of pictures of babies being killed
you're a [ __ ] liar
it's lies
and if you're pro-democracy out there if
you want to stand
for the vote for the people for women
for children all around this country and
to save lives now
is the time to get engaged
for our democracy
engage in the ballot
because they're coming for it
they're coming for the ballot your
ballot they're coming for it
mark my words doubt me
oh tony they'll never overturn roe v
wade you can't overturn roe v wade oh
well susan collins says oh well i'm
reassured that brett kavanaugh
and amy comey barrett and neil gorsuch
will not overturn roe v wade
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you're gonna trust susan collins
if susan collins came out today and said
oh there's no way
there's no way that republicans that the
gqp that the fascist the nazi party that
they are
the despicable [ __ ] put nazis
there's no way they'll try to try to
bang up the woman's vote try to prevent
women and feminists everywhere from
voting bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
hide and watch
hide
and
watch
or or
you can get on your feet
and you can go engage in the ballot
and enough of this [ __ ] it's his
fault it's her fault it's his fault and
hits shut the [ __ ] up
it's enough blaming ourselves
now is the time to not press blame now
is the time to fight who gives a [ __ ]
whose fault this is
who gives a good god damn who did what
and who said what and who when and who
where
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
more of that is gonna cause
more of fascism that's right you're you
stand around pointing fingers at whose
fault this is and you don't go up on
that hill and you fight for that ballot
you will lose you will [ __ ] lose and
everyone out there listening to my voice
continually says over and over and over
again
democrats don't have a message they
never have a message they can't get on
message they can't find a message they
can't message worth a [ __ ]
it ain't up to the politicians folks
the pro-lifers the people that want to
strip away women's liberty the
anti-woman party
that is the gqp
they're organized folks they're [ __ ]
organized and they're ready to whip your
ass and take your rights and make this a
fascist state
they're ready
they're not just gonna stop at the
[ __ ] red states they're not just
gonna go oh well texas and florida and
kentucky you know missouri at there's no
abortion clinics there so now we're done
we're over we're good we're good to go
no
they're coming
they're coming for the blue states
they're going to do everything they can
to take away safe medical procedures for
women
because they [ __ ] hate women making
choices about their bodies
especially when it comes to
stockpiling their country full of
low-income workers
that's right
you think it man you think they give a
[ __ ] about life
you think they give two [ __ ] shits
about children these are the same
[ __ ] that are sexualizing your
children's gender with legislation
they're trying to marry children with
legislation in states
they were locking children up in cages
at the border
you think they give a [ __ ] about human
life and children get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
now is the time
now
yesterday two weeks ago a month ago
they have awakened a sleeping giant
and my message to them
to the fascists in this country
you
have no idea what the [ __ ] woke is
you sons of [ __ ]
you have no [ __ ] clue
so i implore you fight fight fight fight
fight
democracy is worth every single little
inch
so go on that hill and fight for liberty
with the ballot use the ballot use
democracy against them
they fear it the most that's why that's
why you see
you see marsha blackburn this morning
we need we didn't find who leaked this
they're all they're highly concerned
with who leaked it
they don't give a good god damn
about the liberty that is about to be
stripped away from human beings in our
country
don't give two [ __ ]
the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not
liberty
it's in our intro folks
the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people
is
not
liberty
liberty is what we strive for in our
democracy it has been
for hundreds of years
is it perfect no democracy's not perfect
why should it be
should we strive for perfection
certainly
but not everyone is going to get what
they want out of a democracy
they're fighting
to oppress your rights
we
us pro-democracy people
are fighting to preserve
their liberty
and that's the greatest part about
democracy folks
that's the greatest
part is we get to die on the hill of
liberty
where we defend not our right
to liberty
we defend everyone's right even their
right to liberty
that's what it's about
we've come a long way and we got a long
[ __ ] way to go
especially with these [ __ ] fascists
because they not only want to tear down
your liberty they want to tear down our
democracy they want to rip up and [ __ ]
on our constitution
they do not like democracy they have
decided that democracy affords everyone
they hate the liberty that they only
want to have
let me say it again
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not
liberty
and if your goal
no matter what no matter what
what system that you're using in our
government
rather it be the legislative system
inside states or the federal legislative
system
whether you're using executive orders
governors
the president of the united states
are you using our supreme court
to take away the rights of other people
that
is not
liberty
i don't give a [ __ ] who they are
who they want to be what color their
skin is how tall they are how skinny
they are how fat they are i don't give
two shits what religion they are
what gender they identify as who they
love i don't give a [ __ ]
if they're willing to take their liberty
so haphazardly
they will come
for yours
that's what fascists do
and they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop here they're
going to oh
finally we overturn roe v wade okay now
we can
go back underneath our rocks
crawl back underneath them and hide away
they're not going to stop at roe v wade
this whole state's right [ __ ]
they're gonna give you that argument
they're gonna sling that [ __ ] at you all
day long
over and over and over and over again
states right states rights
are the states rights more important
than human rights
do the state's rights
are they way more important than human
rights are they
maybe that's a good question
to ask one of these anti-woman
trump pumping fools
because that's the cheering that's going
on folks
that's the cheering
and democrats all around
the the social media network
that is our internet are playing right
into their hands
trump got us the supreme court picks
and what do liberals do
what do the [ __ ] libs do
oh yeah it's his fault and her fault and
his fault and hare's fault and her fault
and his fault
they know how to divide us they know how
they're very [ __ ] good at it they've
done it for decades how do you think we
are where we are now
because they're good at dividing us
the fascists are damn good at convincing
the people who want to fight for
democracy that they're on opposite sides
there's only there's
there's only two sides right now folks
only two
only two there's only one goddamn line
and you're either you're either on one
side or the other you're either a
fascist and you want to tear down our
democracy or your pro-democracy and you
want to preserve it that's it
we're not federalist and anti-federalist
anymore get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] states right [ __ ] oh well the
state's rights the federal government's
rights blah blah blah blah blah get out
of here with that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
we are not divided federalist
anti-federalist in this country anymore
that is all [ __ ]
and to say that the state has the right
to take away women's rights
to take away human rights get the [ __ ]
out of here we done did this [ __ ] with
slavery oh slavery's about states rights
civil war wasn't about slavery is about
states rights yeah states rights to
grant human beings to own other human
beings
that's what the civil war is about is
slavery
this fight here is not about [ __ ]
states rights i'm gonna show you a god
damn clip of what they're gonna do with
these states rights next
the state's rights to take women's vote
away from them the state's rights to
kill gay marriage the state's rights to
kill
interracial marriage and i use the word
kill specifically
i'm using that word intentionally folks
they're ready
they're ready have you seen the videos
of these people saying when can we shoot
them at charlie kirk's events when can
we shoot them when can we start shooting
these people
have you seen the comments on twitter on
facebook on tick tock on instagram
we have a choice folks
and rather rather you participate and
engage with your feet in our democracy
or not you're choosing
you're choosing if you choose not to
engage if you choose to just cover your
eyes and say you know what
what's done is done
then you're choosing autocracy because
that's the choice autocracy
or democracy
and they want you to choose
i mean they want you to quit
they want you to give up
they want you to not fight
they want autocracy over democracy
that's what they want they're ready
they're willing to fight they're they're
up on the hill
they picked their hill to die on
we going to stand down in the valley and
try to coax them down in the valley to
have a
a real nice conversation with us
try to convince them that oh well your
idea stuck
we have so much better line item bills
we got all kinds of bills that we want
to pass we want to cancel student debt
stay down in the valley stay down in the
valley and try to convince the the
fascists to come down
and talk to you about cancelling your
student debt
or we can all look at each other and go
you know what the only way to cancel
student debt
the only way to cancel student debt
is to absolutely destroy with our ballot
this scourge of fascism in our country
we
the people can do that
we can decide
yes we have our differences and yes we
may blame this person or that person or
this person but we ain't got time for
that kind of [ __ ]
we do not have time for that [ __ ]
and while they're standing around
trying to figure out who leaked this
decision as if that's what [ __ ]
matters
oh man
who leaked it forget about the liberty
being taken away from americans
and human beings human rights
forget about that forget about that we
want to know who leaked this information
and gave
and gave women in this country and
protesters in this country and
pro-democracy people in this country a
head start
that's what they're scared of
doubt me
so what are you going to do
you're going to stand around fighting
with each other
over which democrats going to cancel
student debt which democrats going to
not cancel student debt are you going to
do that are you going to go fight the
fascism
i want to cancel student debt do you
well we ain't going to do that [ __ ] you
think these [ __ ] are going to
cancel your student debt
they may cancel your right to [ __ ]
live
they're already doing it with women
right now as we speak
they want to cancel the right of women
to live
you don't even get to have a life-saving
medical procedure
there's a long history of the pro-life
movement in this country
long history
the ins and outs the bigotry
the way they used abortion as a cudgel
to divide us
to gain political power
to press their systematic racism
to press their anti-woman views on the
entire country
and we have fought back for decades
and fought back and fought back and
fought back
and now
now is not the time
to stop fighting
and using our weapon of the ballot
to win
this
battle because folks it's a battle
they're not going to stop they're not
going to quit they're not going to
it's not going to happen
and they're not going to stop it
overturning roe v wade oh they'll be
excited it'll be gross as [ __ ] that
they're going to be cheering that
americans had their liberties stripped
away from them
but they're not going to stop
not at the red states they'll come for
the blue states
they'll come for the 19th amendment mark
my words
they'll chip away and chip away and chip
away
they're not gonna want women to vote are
you kidding me not at this point goddamn
women are gonna try to vote to codify
roe v wade
if you're pro-democracy out there and
you are hearing my voice
it is time
it is time to band together
with anyone who will stand with the
pro-democracy people in this country and
who will fight to save
our democracy
which is the shining city on the hill of
western democracy
because ultimately
it's not just us that's at stake
all around the
they're women
they're human beings human rights at
stake
and it's up to us
it may be up to us
to show them how important those human
rights are
here in this country
where we
say
our intention is life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
we have to prove it
and today is the day
to start proving it
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking